my father had an accident when he was a
young man he said look everyone has
their burden to bear in life and the key
is not being defined by those it's
overcoming them it's turning your own
path deciding what you want your life to
be and you live it out
[Music]
hi and welcome to the sunday special I'm
eager to welcome to the program our
guest Daniel Krauthammer the son of
Charles Krauthammer now reminder there
will be one question at the end a very
special question you only get the answer
if you become a subscriber over at daily
wire so we're gonna jump into our
interview in just one second but first
let's talk about your impending death I
know we're all gonna plotz at some point
but life insurance is one of those
topics that everybody ought to know
something about and everybody ought to
have do you feel that you understand
life insurance well enough to buy it
well if you're an insurance expert or
newbie policy genius has created a
website that makes it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice and get
covered policy genius is indeed the easy
way to get life insurance and minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find the coverage you need at a
price you can afford it is just the
responsible thing to do from there just
apply online the advisors at policy
genius will handle all the red tape for
you they'll even negotiate your rate
with the insurance company no extra fees
no Commission sales agents just helpful
advice personalized service and policy
genius doesn't just do life insurance
they also allow you to get disability
insurance or homeowners insurance or
auto insurance they can help you get
covered fast so no matter how much or
how little you know about life insurance
you can find the right policy in minutes
at policy genius.com
again that's policy genius the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance go
check them out at policy genius comm
it's just the responsible thing to do
make sure that your family's taken care
of god forbid something happens to
policy genius.com
all right Daniel thanks so much for
joining the show I really appreciate you
being here
no thank you Ben for having me it's it's
good to be with you and I appreciate you
having me on well I want to lead off by
number one expressing my condolences for
the loss of your father who was an icon
in the conservative movement and also
somebody who I really grew up reading
and trying to hone myself after I wrote
a eulogy after he passed away in which I
talked about how in my early career
you're 17 you're 18 you're looking at
which writers do I want to be like and
early on I was thinking how about like
Ann Coulter right she she has a lot of
funny lines and she and she hits people
really hard and then as I got older I
realized that the writer that I most
wanted to be liked was was your dad
because he actually considered issues
incredibly deeply I realized that as
news broke he was usually the opinion I
was looking to first for what's a reason
take on the issues and so I think there
are a lot of conservatives who are my
age older conservatives too are very
grateful that your dad was
there to provide that sort of sort of
guideposts before we get into the book
and and talking about your dad first
when we talk about you what's your
background what do you do yeah so my own
life has been on a bit of hold these
last 18 months now since my father
ghadiyal I was spent 10 months with him
in hospital and then in all the time
since then committed myself to finishing
the book for him and launching the book
and making sure his legacy was secured
my own background is in political
science and economics and business I did
a lot of work in policy and I'm wrote
quite a bit on political issues myself
the last several years went to business
school worked in technology and startups
and to degree I'm really still figuring
out what my my full path in life will be
and so this has been the number one
priority in my life for all this time
but you know now that you know I'll
finally be able to get back to my own
life all take a breath and figure out
where I can best contribute going
forward well I mean it's beautifully
edited book and you've done an amazing
job of it you're telling me off the air
that you've also been paying tribute to
your dad by going around and saying
Kaddish on a daily basis at very
synagogue those mornings might want to
talk a little bit about that yeah I mean
it's a very you know personal private
thing that is not you know something
I've talked about or made a big deal of
but you know it's a Jewish tradition
that you say the mourners Kaddish which
is a prayer for close family who have
passed and that you do that for a full
year after the passing of a parent and
it's something I started doing and just
felt to me like a very meaningful way to
connect with my father and being neither
of us were or are very religious or kind
of believers in the literal sense but
being Jewish was incredibly core and
important to who my father was and and
his whole identity and is to me as well
and so connecting through that has been
an important and meaningful thing for me
so I think for a lot of conservatives
who listen to the show and
no my work they know that I've
considered here your father the
formative conservative thinker probably
from since the 1980s at the very least
and but but there are a lot of folks who
are listening who may not know your
father's biography they may not know
actually sort of the timeline of your
father's life and it's it's really an
incredible story of perseverance and
tragedy and triumph I was wondering if
you might be able to tell us a little
bit about that yeah sure I guess
you know one element I think you're
referencing in there is that my father
had an accident when he was a young man
a diving accident where he severed his
spinal cord and left him in a wheelchair
and that's something he I think you know
overcame and really didn't let define
his life in any important way and that
was really his commitment to himself and
how he lived his life and and he did
live the life that he wanted to and you
know on that note one of the most
incredible things he said about it that
I only discovered after his passing
actually was he said look everyone has
their burden to bear in life everyone
has their cross to bear some of those
are more visible and some of those arms
some of those are burdens you carry on
the inside and no one ever knows about
but everyone has these travails these
slings and arrows that life throws at
you and the key is not being defined by
those it's overcoming them it's charting
your own path deciding what you want
your life to be and you live it out and
that was something that I think comes
through in the book and in his writing
and it's just part of who he was in an
amazing way and you know the way he
lived out that life and the way he found
his meaning and his calling was in
politics and writing and it took him a
while to find that actually he he was
always interested in politics and study
that as an undergraduate and a graduate
student but he had he was studying
political philosophy at Oxford actually
and had a despit of a crisis of
conscience is how he described it and
thought that he was getting kind of
spiraling out into this world of theory
and it was detached from the world and
he wanted to make sure he did something
that mattered that would
have a concrete difference and impact
and so he switched paths and and went to
medical school and actually left Oxford
in the middle of his program to go to
Harvard for that and he ended up going
into psychiatry which he thought would
be as he described it kind of this
middle path between the world of theory
and thought and of hard evidence and
science and medicine and went to Harvard
went through there he went did his
residency at Mass General became chief
resident there so it was a practicing
doctor for many years but came to a
point where he realized this isn't what
he was supposed to be doing that he he
felt still he was always thinking and
talking about politics and that he
thought he regretted having let that go
and really with at my mother's
encouragement mainly is how he always
talked about it decided okay I'm going
to reorient my life and do what I feel I
should be doing there's a lot of
interesting twists in terms of the story
but he managed to get a job while still
working in medicine in DC so I moved to
DC where he figured okay that's where
they do politics so once I get there
I'll meet people and figure it out he
started writing submitting samples got a
few things published through that
applied for and got a job as a
speechwriter for Walter Mondale actually
which surprises a whole lot of people
especially conservatives and worked for
Mondale in 1980 and then Carter lost the
election and the day Reagan was sworn in
actually was my father's first day of
his the rest of his career as a
journalist he started working at the New
Republic magazine which is where he
worked in the early 80s won the National
Magazine Award there and then started
writing his column for The Washington
Post in 1985 I think it was yes which is
also when I was born won the Pulitzer
Prize for his writing there in 87 and it
just kind of went from there his column
was syndicated and gradually grew to
more and more papers eventually about
400 was what it was when he passed he
did started doing TV appearances
eventually in the 90s through the 2000s
was on a a PBS and locally syndicated
show called inside Washington in the
2000s he started doing appearances on
Fox and then became essentially a
nightly panelist on special report first
with Brit Hume and then Bret Baier and
you know really his writing career I
think in many ways was you know very you
know his thoughts were very constant and
his the I think the build in his those
who read him those who followed him was
also very constantly growing and
solidifying base over decades really and
so by the time he passed he left behind
an incredible corpus of work and as you
say a legacy that so many people read
him over so many years yeah I had the
pleasure of meeting him a couple of
times once actually with when I was
working at Breitbart and we went to his
office and what was hilarious about it
is that I expected that he was going to
be ensconced in the news that he was
going to be having the TV's on and
wasn't any of that yeah he was just
sitting there reading and then we came
and he wanted to talk baseball well and
and get to baseball in a little bit the
second time I met him who was that it
was maybe a couple of years ago he was
doing a video for Prager University
and he started we were talking about
healthcare and he started asking me very
specific questions about the differences
between for example the Australian
healthcare system and the Canadian
healthcare system for a second I thought
he was testing me that I realized he
actually wanted to know the answers
because that's the kind of person that
he was when I think of him as a
conservative there there are two ways in
which I think of him as a conservative
one is in terms of his values and what
is in terms of sort of his manners they
kind of Russell Kirk conservatism where
he was somebody who seemed gradualist
akin his pursuit of change he wasn't a
radical he wasn't somebody who was
interested in tearing things out by the
roots whose very considered he was very
polite and maybe that wasn't enough for
some people in the conservative movement
but I wonder if you could talk about
each of those in turn number one sort of
his conservative manner and then also
what do you think were sort of his
unifying core political values sure
so yeah in manner I think I mean I guess
you
to your point you could consider some of
that conservative I think to degree was
just innately who he was he was you know
he was a very kind and thoughtful and
curious person you know he was very
outwardly focused he didn't make a big
deal of himself he didn't focus on
himself in his writing or his life that
much and he was generally interested in
people like when he met you or and when
want to ask you what your thoughts were
or your opinions were or a subject he
discovered they didn't know anything
about before and he had this across a
variety of topics both political and
otherwise I mean one thing I remember
when I was young is he was always so
interested in physics and astrophysics
and cosmology he actually Riaan rolled
in his 40s in a physics course and
Georgetown University just so he could
bone up on his linear algebra and
multivariable calculus so he could kind
of read some of the most recent physics
theory a little more in-depth but I
think that always that kind of really
thinking about what mattered taking a
step back and and considering the bigger
questions in life gave him a perspective
of of course why you know why would you
not be kind of interested to someone why
would you be histrionic in your in your
attitude when you're talking about
politics why would you make it personal
either that I'm always right or that you
are bad because we disagree I think he
he was a very ideas focused person and
that's what that's what brought him to
that life that's why he left medicine
because he cared about these ideas
deeply but it was about the ideas not
about the people advocating them or
arguing against them and I think he
always had that sense of let's put the
ideas out there let's argue about them
and through that we'll get to a better
sense of the truth and I think that
informed his approach personally and
also to your second point to his core
political philosophy you know there was
both a very coarse strain of classical
liberalism to my father's beliefs of of
19th century enlightenment in 18th
century enlightenment thinking of of
free thought of the argumentation of
best
ideas in competition to discover the
best truths the best way of doing things
yet he was a student of John Stuart Mill
I would say is probably his favorite
political philosopher he was actually
writing his dissertation at Oxford about
John Stuart Mill when he left to go into
medicine and I think he always held that
at the very core of his political
thinking of what politics should be
built upon is the idea of the free and
autonomous individual and how he built a
society that we remain free that we have
the open exchange of ideas we have a
pluralism pluralistic society that's
tolerant that is diverse in terms of
thought and where individuals are free
to interact create associations with
each other and on their own free from
the interference of a government that
forces anything thought or otherwise so
that that core idea of classical
liberalism and pluralism and in underlay
everything that he he really thought
about what the right and the good kind
of politics were and to him the American
experiment was the greatest incarnation
of that in human history and the
luckiest and one that we should be
grateful for that it took these geniuses
in the 18th century that that built this
system that endured because it saw that
we're imperfect people it was a
government built for men not angels and
realized that we would have to take our
faults into account in constructing our
politics to balance our sins against our
virtues and my father had such a deep
appreciation for that and and I think
that appreciation connected to what you
identified of you know a real
conservatism to is his thinking too in
that he had incredible respect and
gratitude for the wisdom of the past
that I think in his experience through
life you saw many times the kind of
enthusiasm Zoar romanticism zuv whatever
the political ideology of the time was
saying that oh we have found the truth
the new thing that makes all the other
knowledge from before obsolete we know
what is virtuous and good
and that a usually leads to a a
totalitarianism of some kind or other of
well if you're against the new utopia
we've discovered you must be a bad
person you must be wrong and evil and
that under undercuts pluralist and free
society and secondly you know who are
you to think that you have discovered
some truth that mankind it's all in all
its wisdom and all the sages and
thinkers and theologians we've had with
the centuries were were unable to figure
out that why are you so confident that
you have just discovered this truth and
they didn't know what they were talking
about and so I think my father saw that
incredible value of continuity over time
of maintaining the best from the past
and he talks about this in in the book
there's a commencement speech he gave at
McGill actually where he talks about
this and he has this line he says save
the best you know look to the past for
the wisdom and and what we can preserve
and keep that works and that doesn't
mean everything stays static it doesn't
mean that we don't change it doesn't
mean that that our thinking doesn't
evolve and it doesn't mean that there
are in Justices and bad ideas we inherit
from the past but you have to look at
everything skeptically you have to think
you know if it comes from the past and
it's survived at least there's some
evidence that it's not self-destructive
you know it it has survived we can
analyze we can look use history as a
guide as kind of the empirical evidence
for how this works and if you have a
brand new idea well by definition you
don't have the empirical evidence yet it
hasn't been tested and so you should
look at it just as you look at anything
new you you want to test it out you want
to see how it actually works in the
world and so I think a lot of just what
you said the idea of gradualism I think
is a very good match for how my dad
approached a lot of these questions if
he wasn't against change but he said
look let's let's take this slow let's
have respect for the values that we've
inherited from the past and let's think
about these things very carefully you
know spend just last week I was giving a
talk about my dad in the book and I I
just had you know
was thinking about just these ideas and
it occurred to me I was I remembered you
know William Buckley is lying about the
conservative is someone who stands at
Ward history and yells stop and I was
thinking you know that doesn't that's
not who my dad was but I put it I was
thinking a variation on that that you
know my father I imagine standing with
Ford history and yelling think so I had
you know I guess there's a lot in there
but I think he he had you know these
very core very thought-out political
principles that he always looked to
whenever he was arguing whatever the
political you know controversy or idea
of the day was and so that was something
I noticed in putting the book together
and reading all his things and his
pieces articles from decades that it
could always connect back to these deep
bills this deep philosophical core and
you know I think he held that with him
his whole life and that was what
mattered him about his vocation about
writing about politics and I think
that's one of the things that people
felt so much even if you know they
didn't see it in every single day I
think these really core ideas this sense
of commitment to principles and being
honest about them and following through
on your own you know the logic of your
own thinking to the endpoint wherever
those chips may fall whatever the ideas
end up being without regard for yourself
or your party or you know what what team
you're on so to speak I think that
really defined my dad as a thinker so no
ii don't ask you about some of the
controversy surrounding him particularly
on the foreign policy side but first
let's talk about postage rates they've
gone up again thankfully stamps calm can
ease the pain with big discounts off
post office retail rates with stamps
calm you save five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 40% off Priority
Mail that kind of savings who really
adds up especially for small businesses
Plus stamps calm is completely online
and that saves you time no more
inconvenient trips to the post office
stamps com automatically calculates and
prints the exact amounts of postage you
need for every letter or package you
said you're never going to overpay or
under pay again stamps.com brings all of
the services of the US Postal Service
direct to your fingertips by and prints
official US postage for any letter
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer they'll send you a
free digital scale it automatically
calculates exact postage stamps comm
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs stamps comm
saves you money they give you postage
discounts you can't get at the post
office including five cents off every
first class stamp I use stamps comm
because it saves me time and it saves me
money I don't want to slap stuff down to
the post office you don't have to either
right now my listeners get a special
offer it includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale see for
yourself why over 700 thousand small
businesses use stamps comm just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that stamps comm enter Shapiro
alright so I want to ask you about the
controversy surrounding your father so I
think that your your father was not a
man made for the Twitter age
particularly because he did consider
ideas deeply and because I mean even in
what I read of how he would write you
know having to go through columns over
and over to get the perfect wording I
mean I wish I had that sort of
commitment to my own writing I'm too
busy with turd but I this he didn't seem
like he was made for the Twitterverse
per se and after his passing there were
a number of folks on the Left who
immediately decided they were gonna
recast his legacy as entirely about the
Iraq war and suggest that he was a war
mongering neocon I was wondering what
were the kind of unifying principles
behind his foreign policy because that
became the most controversial part of
his of his legacy yeah you know well he
wrote about foreign policy and cared
about it deeply that was I think one of
the areas where you know he read the
most thought the most and really put
forth some of the most original and
powerful arguments and there's a lot of
it in the book and his thinking as with
so many things I discovered stayed
incredibly consistent over the holes for
decades of his career that there's
articles in the book all the way back
from the 80s lining out principles that
he laid out that stayed the same and
there's one in the book I think that
speaks very much to this in a general
sense it's called when to intervene and
you know this is the question as you say
that you know he was criticized a lot
for and you know the big debate and
important debate on on how involved
America should be overseas what what
role its role should be
in this piece as well as others my
father always argued for a strong
American foreign policy one that's
active in the world but he was also
extremely careful and thoughtful about
where America should be actually taking
action that would be a commitment of
blood and treasure because that he saw
is a you know a sacred trust to to
commit that among your citizens but be
something that America does not have
unlimited power it can't do everything
everywhere all the time
and so it is important to to choose
where it really counts and the criteria
he laid out were were a that any
intervention be morally justified by our
values of being against genocide tyranny
wanton aggression on the part of
dictatorships that it before open
societies free societies freeing captive
populations and be that it be
strategically necessary for the United
States that we can't just be you know
they have a foreign policy of doing
charity for the world that we can't
intervene everywhere that there's an
injustice being done and that we have to
gird our power maintain that and make
sure that we can uphold really the
superstructure of the international
world of certainly international order
of open ceilings of of a world where
borders are respected where where
dictators are afraid to to conquer their
neighbors and so you know there are
examples throughout the 90s and the
2000s where he was for several of the
interventions that we engaged in against
several of the interventions if you go
back and read his columns on the
intervention in the Balkans in Kosovo he
was he I don't want to step too far but
he was he had a lot of criticism of how
those were engaged in there were
arguments in in the 2000s about
intervening in several African countries
in in Darfur in Liberia I think it was
in Libya the intervention they
he was very critical of how how that
happened and that we went went in and
without regard for the strategic plan so
you know he had very complex and
considered thinking on on all of these
and but through it all he he thought
that America had a special role to play
in the world that we can you know he was
a very realistic thinker and I think in
foreign policy that exhibit itself as
being very realistic about how the world
worked and the way he said said it is
look the international arena is a
Hobbesian world it's dog-eat-dog it's
it's you know it's a wild jungle no law
there's no authority to appeal to and
you know what holds the Peace of the
world together and has held it together
since World War two it's been American
power that was his argument that we have
upheld you know through our alliances
through our deterring action against
would-be aggressors we have held the
longest period of major power peace in
in modern history I mean and modern in
terms of centuries not just you know the
last decades and that that's not an
accident it's not coincidence that this
period has aligned with a period when
America has been the world's major power
and has explicitly tried to uphold an
open order that is peaceful and that we
are kind of the ultimate account holders
for and we can wish that we lived in a
world that would be peaceful and stable
if we withdrew and and didn't and didn't
uphold this and spend the resources and
the time and energy that it requires but
that world simply doesn't exist and that
he you know he saw a lot of I would say
the the objections to his point of view
both on the right and the left of kind
of withdrawing American forces whether
it's because you think America is acting
unjustly in the world which perhaps the
left would think or that or the world
doesn't deserve our efforts which
perhaps someone on the right would think
he would say I think he often
viewed those as as misguided in their
philosophy but also in their their
realistic appraisal of the world that
you can wish that we can be safe and
that America can prosper in a world that
we withdraw from but history has shown
us otherwise and it would be unwise for
us to give up all that we've built in
terms of that international order that
both maintains our safety and creates a
world that is largely aligned with our
most dearly held values how did he feel
about the flip inside the Republican
Party particularly over the Iraq war
which is again the the major sticking
point for so many people who criticized
your father inside the Republican Party
there seemed to be a shift from
universal sympathy for the Iraq war to
as things went more poorly for a while a
turn against the Iraq war particular in
the aftermath of finding no stockpiles
of newly produced weapons of mass
destruction to the point where the 2016
nominee was a man who legitimately got
on stage and called President Bush a war
criminal and suggested that we never
should have invaded Iraq except to take
the oil how do you feel about sort of
the evolution inside the the
conservative movement in the Republican
Party concerning the Iraq war you know
to be honest I don't know specifically
how he felt about that development
within the Republican Party is
differentiated from a general trend but
you know if and there are several
columns in the book about this to
because it was you know it was an
important thing that he wrote about and
had a lot of considered arguments on but
there's one where he talks about I think
a lot of the points you're saying and at
this point it wasn't just the Republican
Party it was you know 70 percent
supporting the war and you know most
major Democrats also voting for it so
you know a lot of the country shifted on
this and you know this was a long debate
of you know was it a mistake was it not
and you know my father always said about
that you know it's it's somewhat a he
somewhat rejected the premise of the
question that you know oh if you knew
then what would you have said and and
you know his argument in the book is
well I mean the debate would have not
come up the way it did if we knew then
and you know there's there's legitimate
you know he very wrestled with and
argued really on the level of people who
said it at the time but
were actually two of it's not worth it
strategically speaking and and that's
something he said you know reasonable
people of goodwill can absolutely
disagree on this and he was critical at
different points to he supported the the
initial invasion he was very critical
during the occupation and a lot of the
what he saw as mistakes that were made
he was very supportive of the surge and
and you know really by the end of the
surge had has had had said and in
several articles that you know we have
gotten Iraq to a stable place this is
you know not mistakes were made and and
this shouldn't have you know been on
this course necessarily but we're at a
place where we've committed all this
blood and treasure in Iraq is now a
strategic asset and you know he saw the
withdrawal from Iraq in 2011 as a huge
mistake so you know there were as he
described it there are many stages to to
that war and and so the ultimate end
point depends on a lot of those
different decisions at different times
and so he was always you know again very
thoughtful and considered on looking at
where we are at any given point in time
and saying you know what is the best
thing for America to do now what's the
strategically and values why is the
right choice to make at this point in
history rather than you know replaying
hypothetical that goes against the the
very reality of what the knowledge was
at that time okay so in just a second or
to ask you what is the point of it all
but first when the founders crafted the
Constitution the first thing they did
was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by the government the second
right they enumerated was the right of
the population to protect that speech
and their own persons with force you
know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing BCM they were
started in a garage by Marine veteran
more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
you facture life-saving equipment and
they assume that every rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen or a law enforcement officer or
a soldier overseas every component of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans to a life-saving standard
BCM feels a moral responsibility as
Americans to provide tools that are not
going to fail the user when it's not
just a paper target but somebody coming
to do them harm BCM go check them out
right now at bravo company MFG comm
that's Bravo Company MFG comm you can
also go check out some of their videos
at youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
that's youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA ok Daniel so I know big question the
title of the book is the point of it all
so when I read your father wrote one of
most beautiful notes I've ever read in
the last thing that he ever published
about his impending death and talking
about how he felt that he had lived a
fulfilled life and in fact it thought of
such a moving piece of writing that I
quoted at length in my new book because
my new book is all about how the West
has sort of lost his purpose and I use
your father as an example of somebody
who clearly had lifelong purpose to the
point where he could stare death in the
face and write something that beautiful
and brave about it what did your father
think was actually the point of it all
so yeah it's a it's a big question and
obviously it's not a narrow focus in the
title it was one that my mother came up
with actually the title of the book she
came up with the last title the book -
his last title - his last book as well
but really it struck me is exactly right
because I think what he saw is the point
of it all and he writes about this in
several different places is really to
find your own meaning in life that
there's not one overriding truth that
anyone gets to define that everyone must
follow their own loves their own
passions discover what moves them in
family in their job in in their passions
and pastimes and he saw that I think the
point of it all is a diversity of things
that people can and must figure out for
themselves and the the key thing that I
thought made it such a perfect title for
the book was that he found his own
life's purpose in his professional
life as supporting and arguing foreign
maintaining the politics that allowed
that to take place
he saw that individual freedom to choose
to chart your own path and find that own
point as the most precious and valuable
thing that we have and that it's not
something that's existed for a lot of
human history that we have had mostly
regimes and politics that enforce a view
of what the point of life is that give
you the point of life and that define it
for you and that was something he saw as
anathema to the kind of the pluralist
open politics that he cared about so
much that no one should have the power
to dictate to someone else what the
point of their lives should be and that
it's really the the journey and living
out you know one's own inner voice that
must be each and every person's own
individual point and yet he he wasn't a
moral relativist he wasn't somebody who
believed that you could define your own
morality I always hearken back to
President Obama's second inaugural
address where he had what I thought was
legitimately the worst line I've ever
written address where he said that the
job of each person is to define Liberty
in their own way and I thought well no
that's pretty much the one thing we sort
of have to agree on if we're gonna have
a civilized society so while you talk
about young people finding happiness in
a variety of pursuits yeah the reality
is that we do have to share that that
common framework no I think and I think
that's exactly his connection in my
father's philosophy of the personal life
to the political and the communal that
in order for the individual to have that
freedom you have to have a politics that
stays that stays out of it and and how
do you do that you have to have agreed
upon rules of free speech of free
association of you know of the autonomy
of the individual and that to your point
is a political agreement and that really
is in my father wrote in the book quite
a bit about how Mill approached this how
Isaiah Berlin approached this question
of you know it does come to a
philosophical butting of heads
potentially with moral relativism as you
say but the the core value you have to
adopt is that agreement on openness
there has
be the bedrock idea of of the free
individual and how we respect that and
that is the definition of Liberty that's
you know that is John Stuart Mill on
Liberty as so many of the I think really
my father's favorite political
philosophers that he followed were were
the ones who who kind of interpreted
that that classical liberal
enlightenment philosophy for the modern
age now one of the things that I want to
ask about is specifically with regard to
that because there's there's a debate
that's broken out it's kind of an
interesting debate I've been having it
rather openly with with folks like Jonah
Goldberg specifically about that
enlightenment thought my suggestion is
that a lot of the common values that
undergird Enlightenment thought have a
lot deeper roots in judeo-christianity
that the value of the individual I mean
you mentioned the free individual and my
belief is that in a scientific
materialist world it's very difficult to
make the case for the rights of the free
individual capable of making independent
decisions maybe for a ball for Spinoza's
ball of meat wandering through the
universe self believing herself will but
not really self well then none of these
things exist it's hard to build a
political system on the basis of that I
wonder what your dad's of religious
philosophy was because he obviously
wasn't a religious person I don't think
he was an atheist I think he called
himself an agnostic is that correct yeah
he had a I would ascribe as a complex
and and subtle sense of religiosity and
he he grew up actually an Orthodox
Jewish household so he was very
religious when he was young and he he
left that to a degree but but but never
rejected it totally and he talked about
this quite a bit and there's there's
quite a bit in the book too particularly
about how he maintained a sense of
Jewish identity and not just in the
cultural sense but in the sense of the
philosophical heritage of the Jewish
tradition of all the arguments of the
rabbi's going back centuries and to the
Bible and to those core ideas built into
it and he you know as he described it he
wasn't a believer in the literal sense
he didn't feel there was a a you know
and anthropomorphize God who involves
himself in our daily lives but he did
have a very strong belief that there was
some
and greater out there and that as he
described it he thought atheism was the
least believable of all theologies that
was the the phrase he used and he you
know he had an incredible respect for
God the own limitations on our own
knowledge and understanding of ourselves
and of the universe that this was you
know I mentioned he was so interested in
physics and cosmology this was the root
of a lot of it he loved thinking about
the universe and and cosmology in the
history of everything back to the very
beginning and you know he loved
investigating that but he also I think
drew from that a sense that we're never
gonna know the final answers to a lot of
this stuff that he'd like to use there
was a phrase I think it was Newton used
that he when he was trying to kind of
discern some of these universal laws he
said you know I feel like a snail on the
shores of an ocean trying to understand
how the tides work and you know a snail
is never going to understand that it is
beyond the innate capacity and and my my
father talked about this in in terms of
us that there are things we'll never
understand and we should have a certain
respect and awe for that that there are
there are forces and and powers and
things beyond us that we shouldn't
assume we can ever know particularly
don't exist but or or claim to have a
the one true knowledge of where it comes
from but from that I think he had an
incredible respect and and gratitude for
religious tradition in general he had
great respect for religious people
his father was an incredibly religious
person and in a historical sense as well
which he kind of touched on he saw the
the values inculcated by yes the world's
great religions in particular his own
and the judeo-christian tradition as has
getting us to you know better
understanding of our own human nature of
discovering some real important truths
about us that allow you know
historically
allowed us to get to where we are so I
you know I don't want to wade too far
into the debate I know that that you've
had on this topic because I don't want
to speak for my dad beyond what I know
he wrote but you know I would say he
there was both a personal sense of of
that I think some some would see as a
spirituality or a or at the very least
and agnosticism at the most a kind of a
kind of religiosity and in a political
sense a real respect for the history of
where these ideas came from so what was
it like growing up in your house what
about your daddy that was a public
figure yeah
What's Your Mother like and how was it
to be growing up in a house where all of
this was on the table apparently Albany
yeah well I wouldn't say yeah I think
I'm giving a kind of skewed perception
that's how you're reading it going up I
mean you know as as with everyone I
think you grow up the way you grow up
and that's what you know but you know we
did talk about politics and big ideas
and and we enjoyed doing that and but it
was never kind of you know pointed
debates or you know some kind of
structured environment and you know we
you know there's everything else from my
childhood stands out in a lot of ways
just you know fun things like baseball
games and we loved movies and saw those
all the time together going on long car
trips together but you know obviously a
lot of this thought and and thinking he
you know he didn't so much teach me as
he opened up the world for me is how I
would put it that he he always tried to
present all this wealth of knowledge he
had but without telling me how to think
about it and you know that was a
wonderful gift he gave me but you know I
would say much more important is just
the relationship as with anyone just
that you have with your dad it's the
same with my mom I there I'm an only
child very close with both my parents
and no we're very tight kind of you know
a little trio and that
really I think just such a core part of
who I think of when I think of Who am I
and what am I you know I'm you know
Charles and Robbins son and that feeling
of just being of them and from them and
and connected to them as an immense part
of who I feel that I am so your father
was famously a huge baseball fan are you
a big baseball fan the same with your
father I am but not not to his degree I
think it would be hard to top that but
you know I grew up playing baseball and
when I was a kid I was an Orioles fan
because Washington didn't have a team
when I was growing up but when the Nats
did come to DC my dad just fell in love
with them nice there's a there's a
article in the book about how he
literally tried to resist but could not
not fall in love with the Nats but I'd
go to him with games whenever I went
back home to visit and and that was
certainly one of our kind of great fun
things that we did together so what was
his general take on sort of the modern
state of philosophy so we've been
talking about kind of deep ideas your
dad I think of as more of a political
philosopher really than as just a
columnist so a couple of his columns
popped to mind in this vein the the
column that he wrote about stem cell
research is still I think one of the
best pieces of writing on public policy
and personalized public policy I've ever
read because obviously of his medical
condition and then his his statements
about how you separate out from that to
try and make the moral distinctions
between stem cell lines and and all that
you know but so much of politics is not
that so much of politics is the battle
of personalities the slap fight
that we that really has magnified in in
the in the last couple of years and he
stopped writing publicly in what
mid-2017 something like that so did he
talk politics with you
after him between between that the time
you passed away yeah a little bit it was
we were dealing with a lot more
important things but you know we turn on
the news from time to time and you know
healing he shared you know some of the
same frustrations that I have and I'm
sure you have of just what you're saying
some of the more you know histrionic
kind of personalized and and and really
you know divorced from ideas politics of
kind of just you know two teams fighting
each other for
sake of it but I think you know I I do
get asked this a lot and I again not to
speak for him but you know I think in
his own career he was often pleasantly
surprised at his own popularity and how
widely he was read and how much he was
you know watched on Fox and you know
recognized wherever he went it's not
something I think he ever expected or
you know thought he necessarily you know
deserve to have it was just he was doing
what he thought he was he could best
contribute by putting his ideas out
there but the fact that it was received
so widely and so well I think gave him
some hope of you know people do want to
hear thoughtful reasoned arguments and
that's exactly what people would would
say that they read him for so I mean I
think he you know he always saw that
there's room for that argument out there
and if you give it to people in the
right way they'll know they'll be glad
for it and he also had a real a real
deep and inbuilt sense of optimism which
covers this topic I think as well as
many others that you know conservatives
often aren't the most optimistic people
kind of you know if you there's often a
sense of you know things are going
downhill we're losing the values of the
past etc etc and while my father was
extremely realistic he he was not
pessimistic he didn't you know think
that we're all going to hell in a
handbasket or that you know we're losing
our core sense of ourselves he he
definitely saw the dangers he you know
he saw that there were a lot of things
wrong with Howard practice in politics
today just is there a lot of things
dangers in the world beyond our own
politics to deal with but he had a true
sense of optimism and he even used the
word faith in America in particular to
figure things out and to get it right
there's probably my favorite piece in
the book is one called constitutions
conservatism and the genius of the
founders and you know he talks about his
political philosophy and limited
government in particular but at the end
there's a section where he kind of draws
back even more and talks about just his
own personal sense of America and
American
and the incredible unlikeliness that
these these political geniuses as he put
it just appeared in this colonial
backwater in the 18th century and
managed to put together what's still the
most lasting best functioning and form
of government that humanity has yet come
across and they got so much right and
also we had the for the foresight to
know that they weren't perfect to build
in mechanisms to change over time to
build in mechanisms that would balance
out the imperfections of mankind and he
saw that gift from the past along with
what he just described as the core
decency of the American people that he
saw that as something he really just
believed in that we would figure it out
that we had the capacity and showed
again and again in our history the way
he put it was that we redeemed the
mistakes of our past and find ways to
inspire each other and it's something
that actually when I discovered it and
it's something he'd said things like
this in quite a few places it really it
gave me some hope and faith and I
sometimes look back to it when I'm
feeling particularly a pessimistic or
distraught about the the state of things
and puts a smile on my face so you know
it's not sometimes you you do have to
take a leap of faith and and and trust
in people to to figure out the right
thing you mentioned that your father was
an optimist that came through a lot in
his writing I always like to call myself
a pessimist pessimist just because it
means I'm always right eventually
where did he see any trends where he was
deeply troubled by certain trends and
sort of um latter-day America what what
we've seen in the past 10 years
particularly I would hesitate to say he
was kind of completely pessimistic about
anything but I would say where he would
certainly had great worries and he often
focused his attention of trying to
combat what he saw as bad trends were in
the you know where he saw that the
pluralist open liberal democracy that he
thought was the core of what made our
politics work so well was gradually
being chipped away at
and I'd say you know thinking
particularly what's in the book and some
of the pieces I found that and that he
chose that pointed this out most of all
I'd maybe put them into two maybe two
fields just for the sake of this answer
one a little more on the kind of
economic side of things of a state that
gradually grows and grows and provides
more services and and crowds out more
and more of the private sector and more
and more of civil society and voluntary
groups and free and free associations
that that he saw is a a creeping and a
threat and one that's difficult to fight
back to of once you grant an entitlement
as he put it it's very hard to take it
away
and so this was a lot of what he argued
with the left about of how big
government programs should be in health
care and and variety of other areas
where he saw look if you know you can
make arguments for them but in the big
picture that you're going to to take
away some of the core things that matter
most in our system and and to the
American freeway and secondly I'd I'd
say perhaps on the kind of the thought
police you know political correctness
angle that he you know again back to his
core political philosophy believed that
the core most important thing perhaps
was free and open debate and ideas
competing with each other so that the
best could win and there's columns in
the book where he he focuses on this to
of of certain trends he saw particularly
on the left of the effort to shut down
debate before even getting to that
argument and of you know putting saying
that oh the debate is closed on this
we're not going to talk about and we're
gonna you know we're gonna call you
names and and not even let you publish
this and that's something that I think
you know we saw in a few different areas
of debate and you know it's not the end
of the world if what we're perhaps this
issue goes here there but I think that
general trend he saw is you know it's
very important not to let that continue
that we have to uphold above all the
free and open exchange of
and not let our politics define what we
can talk about so you're a political
thinker in your own right you've done a
fair bit of writing about politics are
there any specific areas where you feel
like you really differ from from your
father's political viewpoint either in
policy or in philosophy yeah I mean
there are certainly things we disagreed
on and you know a lot of the stuff we we
you know we didn't debate every single
issue Under the Sun
so you know as I actually went back and
read a lot of his old pieces for for
completing this book came across things
that I I didn't always agree with you
know is I agree with I'd say the most
important things and the core things I I
agreed with him and generally in line
there but I'd say you know on a lot of
economic issues domestic policy issues
we we'd differ a little bit on something
like climate change which I'd say we're
at kind of different points on the
spectrum but you know I think the way I
describe it and I kind of wish our
politics in general worked a little more
like this is on these things it wasn't
you know like he was on one side I was
on the other and we had some debate
where we argued it out a that's kind
about you know I would talk with my dad
but but be you know most issues are not
just there's one side and another side
and let's see which one wins there's on
a lot of things particularly when it
comes to you know a lot of domestic
policy choices you know there's a
spectrum you can you have an extreme on
one end and extreme on the other and
there's a lot of different policy
options and and decisions on you know
we're a moral balance lies in between
and you know I'd say there are points
where PB at one point and I'm I would
say well I wouldn't necessarily say I
disagree with him but I'd be a few
clicks over on that spectrum and you
know it's another question I've been
asked quite a bit lately and I've always
thought you know I kind of wish more
people who disagreed publicly would do
so that way my my dad and I did I'm just
say oh that's interesting well why do
you think that and you know if you
debate it out and say what's the
reasoning behind why you're there
instead of here maybe you'll actually
get to a both to a better point or a
better understanding of where you live
so you mentioned John Stuart Mill I'm
wondering just for the sake of for the
sake of my own knowledge
well what were some of the other
sort of political philosophers other
books that he that he really counted on
admired that they were formational for
him yeah I mean he really went back to
kind of the the Canon of a kind of
enlightenment thought so John Stuart
Mill John Locke Isaiah Berlin in the
book he actually writes an article about
him describing him as for the best
modern interpreter of that classical
liberal tradition also I'd say I'm you
know that the founders as well Madison
in the Federalist Papers talked Ville
kind of and moving a little more towards
let's say that kind of conservative side
of the philosophy we talked about to
Burke and Chesterton and these are all
figures actually that he he mentions in
the book and talks about as either
explicitly people who inspired him or
whose ideas he still holds core and and
thinkers very important were there
anything hers on the left that he
particularly enjoyed kind of going back
and forth with or people he enjoyed read
him um I mean I know he did we you know
we didn't talk a lot about I guess I
didn't talk a lot of shop so to speak
with my dad of you know when we did talk
about it was more about the ideas I'd
say but you know when he he did a lot of
speeches and debates as well not on TV
just for you know events that are hosted
by trade associations or what have you
and and he really enjoyed a lot of those
when he was with someone who we
disagreed with but who was very smart
and thoughtful he loved it you know and
I think he obviously liked winning so to
speak
but but you know I think there was there
was nothing more frustrating to him than
an argument that you know you're just I
have my aside you have yours and we're
just gonna yell at each other for an
hour he saw that as you know what's the
point of this you know his vocation as
you saw it was not to be you know a
cheerleader or an advocate and just say
this point this point this point I think
he really saw as his role as I'm here to
make an argument and if I can't convince
someone then what am I doing here
and he always when he made an argument
always trying to take into account the
other side's assumptions and working
with
those backwards to his own point because
as he said if you if you just are
arguing core assumptions you're very
unlikely to get anywhere and so trying
to have I would call it maybe a kind of
a intellectual generosity to the other
side to actually try to convince them
and not just beat them you know it
doesn't mean you don't make a very sharp
and pointed and and full argument which
he always did but I think he always held
that core to what it meant to be an
honest critic as he said to fully argue
out from his own principles and try to
convince those on the other side that
what the ideas he was putting out there
really were good and better because
otherwise what was he doing how's this
experience of putting together the book
and and touring around with it has that
been for you personally because it must
be I imagine on one hand difficult and
on the other hand must be something yeah
I know you're you're right it's a very
two-handed experience it's all I want
had been to be I was very hard having
gone through this focusing on this you
know completely with every fiber of my
being
and particularly actually going out and
talking about all this stuff so publicly
and also trying to represent my father
as best I can but but not pretending to
speak for him because I don't want to do
that I want to represent what he wrote
and what I know that he thought but I'm
I you know he has his views and and his
he's his own person and I'm not gonna
speak for for you know what he would say
today so it's been emotionally you know
not the easiest thing but on the other
hand it's been incredibly rewarding and
gratifying to be able to do this and it
was incredibly important to me to finish
this for him that he and he asked me to
do it he entrusted it to me and I wanted
to make sure that it was done as he
deserved and up to the standards that he
had set and I'm very grateful that I had
the opportunity to do this and not you
know not everyone who loses a parent can
do something like this for their parent
and so it's you know I think as with so
many things all these last months
it's very difficult but there's
something I think more deeply rewarding
and important that I've been able to do
by going through this process let me not
get to biblical but obviously we've been
doing is an incredible example of Cupid
a via aim it's it's an incredible
example of respect for your for your
father and I think that we're all
grateful that you did that I do have one
final question for I only ask you to do
your best I know it's difficult to sort
of sum up what you think your father's
legacy should be for folks who've never
read him for folks who who didn't spend
years following him and will get that
answer in just a second but if you want
to hear Daniel Krauthammer answer you
have to be a daily wire subscriber to
subscribe go to daily wire comm click
the subscribe button you can hear the
end of our conversation there well thank
you so much for your time and thanks so
much for for all the work that you've
been doing it means a lot to I know
everyone in our audience means a lot to
me and I'm sure that you know his legacy
will certainly carry on so thank you so
much for stopping by really appreciate
thank you
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia and Guillot the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]